welcome to ugly veil friend wake up box
ladies and gentlemen it's blake shelton
the act or that's kind of weird is this
yeah yeah I've done a few little acting
things before but but this is definitely
my first big role and anything maybe my
last two I don't know I haven't seen the
movie yet I have no idea are you gonna
see you today yeah I'm gonna walk in and
see it for the first time and and I'm
excited I got some good reviews from
from these people who saw the movie
already so that's good I don't know I
don't know what to expect my question is
how do you go from the sexiest man alive
to the mayor of ugly vision that's it
it's a long fall I don't know I think
this is this is probably more
appropriate than the other one to begin
with but I I gotta say I don't know you
know who who all is involved in the
movie I've only worked with the
directors and a couple of the producers
but whoever wrote this script I mean
it's such a great message and it's a
great message for for kids great message
for adults okay so follow me on this
this scenario you know Kelly's in the
movie right your buddy Kelly yeah so in
the movie your character gets kidnapped
mm-hmm god forbid that would ever happen
in real life
but if Blake Shelton were kidnapped in
real life what Kelly Clarkson save him
oh I like to think she would yes yeah
okay yeah you know Kelly and I have it
definitely have a brother-sister kind of
relationship and we might say awful
things to each other but if somebody
else says something awful to us you know
that's their that's you know that's
breaking the rules right you don't mess
around with family family can talk about
family but somebody else does make a
deal that's right that's that's kind of
how it's been you know for a long time
with she and I it's we've just been
really close for a long time you know
even way before the voice so of course
any project I'm involved in seems like
where we're involved in you're locked
together you're tethered together by the
way
it is family day today for you guys you
brought win and the kids and everybody
out today so they're so excited yeah the
kids
I don't know how kids get so much
information these days they know way
more about this movie that I would do
yeah they're like you know hey you know
talking to me about scenes that I
haven't seen as I would you see that
well it's on the internet you tweeted it
like I did what are you talking about so
they've been looking forward to it for a
long time they got your voice awed might
have they seen anything they would they
think about your voice being an animated
character well there's there's one scene
that Apollo the youngest has watched
already about 30 times it's on the
trailer and it's a scene where the
jibberish cats doesn't run I don't know
what he does but something about that is
it's already fascinating to him so I
think my cool my cool points are going
up a little bit with the kids which I
need all the help I can well I noticed
that he does look like today Apollo a
mash-up of you and Gwen style and the
best possible words look at that he's
got his cowboy boots on his jean jacket
but then he's got a little leopard print
so I know I know he's a rock and roll
cowboy thank thank God one of the one of
the guys in this group has some style
I'm can I ask you real quick cuz I know
you have new music out God's country
already skyrocketing to the charts yeah
and I don't sit here and say that you're
not a singer cuz I know you like to
diminish it all the time you like to be
self-deprecating I had to get a run at
that one to hit those notes for sure
it's a hasn't one of the more
challenging vocals that I've ever
recorded and and then I performed it on
the ACM Awards and for the first time in
my career I've got a song that I have to
actually warm up to go to you know my
songs are you know most of them are down
the middle I'm a country singer and so
most of my melodies that I record anyway
or you know things that I can easily
seen this one pushes me to to my limits
though but that's that's fun I love a
challenge this movie is a lot about
overcoming your insecurities and and
your differences and embracing how
unique you are when you're the SEC
his Man Alive it's hard to believe you
have insecurities but how do you deal
with it when you have those days where
you're just feeling like I don't know if
I belong I don't know this is right you
know I've got the most gorgeous woman in
the world on my arm like how did I
deserve this
well each time I'm feeling doubtful
about myself you know I you know I drink
a lot right well so it's sometimes it'll
start earlier in the day
[Music]